quand on les votes l'agriculture
biologique on a souvent en tête l'image
d'une petite ferme maraîchère de
quelques hectares ou plus mais le visage
du bio est en pleine transformation en
saskatchewan deux frères cultive plus de
dix neuf mille hectares de terres en bio
ça c'est à peu près la taille de toute
l'île d'orléans au complet une ferme à
grande échelle qui vient avec des défis
tout aussi grand
prête en 2019
[Musique]
au coeur des prairies les semis battent
leur plein
travis rice est l'un des plus importants
producteurs de graines en saskatchewan
il cultive des céréales des légumineuses
et des oléagineux sur plus de 19 mille
hectares sans aucun produit chimique des
cultures biologiques
c'est comme ça qu'on cultivées autrefois
dans ce chan ils s'aiment du blé sont en
grève c'est la luzerne qui surgit déjà
du sol
[Musique]
la luzerne développe un système
racinaire incroyable qui fixe la zone
c'est comme si on avait des camions de
regret partout dans le champ
[Musique]
cette approche est nouvelle pour travis
ride
il a grandi sur une ferme
conventionnelle près d'ici mon frère et
moi ont pulvérisé tous les produits
chimiques sur les cultures on devait
porter des vêtements protecteurs et des
masques en raison de leur toxicité
soldats comme bon nombre de jeunes
adultes
travis raed quitte la ferme familiale
pour se trouver du travail en ville à
calgary
mais en 2014
il décide de revenir en saskatchewan
comme la ferme de ses parents a été
vendu il se cherche des terres mais les
prix sont exorbitants
[Musique]
les coûts de l'agriculture avait doublé
et même triplé seulement sept ou huit
ans avant il fallait prévoir 100 $
l'âcre pour l'achat des êtres et tout à
coup on était rendu à 350 dollars
il décide alors avec son frère guérite
de s'associer à un propriétaire qui leur
prête ses terres en échange d'une part
des profits tirés de leur exploitation
comme il s'agissait surtout de pâturage
la culture biologique s'y prêtait bien
ces terres étaient parfaits pour la
culture biologique parce qu'il n'avait
jamais reçu de produits chimiques
ils sèment des cultures conventionnelles
et quelques champs de culture biologique
ils constatent que leur culture bio
rapporte presque trois fois plus que
leurs cultures conventionnelles nous
quelques chants culture bio mon père
m'en dès la première année de payer
toutes nos dépenses
une véritable révélation ont saisi l'an
prochain tout beaux chants seront bio
mais l'agriculture biologique a la
réputation de ne pas être viable à long
terme
donc c'est devenu pour nous un défi à
relever l'année suivante les frères
wright achètent leurs propres terres
qu'ils convertissent en culture
biologique processus qu'ils mettront
trois ans a complété la ferme
grandit rapidement de 12 cents hectares
en culture biologique en 2015 elle passe
à plus de 19 mille hectares quatre ans
plus tard c'est la plus grande ferme
céréalière biologique au pays
il cultive presque toujours une céréale
est une légumineuse dans un même champ
la culture intercalaire est l'une des
stratégies principales pour remplacer
les engrais chimiques qu'ils voient
lentilles à pois chiche
ce sont toutes des plantes qui fixe
leurs propres à hot wheels
c'est à zot s'infiltre dans le sol dans
lequel on sème aussi du blé ou de l'orge
c'est comme des amis qui partagera un
dîner à l'école en plus la diversité
semble prévenir les maladies
les frères wright font le pari que les
prix de vente élevé obtenu pour leur
culture bio leur permettront de financer
l'expansion rapide de leurs fermes
mais la transition vers le bio deviendra
aussi une quête personnelle j'ai
commencé à remettre en question
l'agriculture conventionnelle
on utilise des produits chimiques pour
des cultures qu'on mange
alors que la plupart des gens refusent
même d'en mettre dans le jardin jouent
leurs enfants
les fermiers ne sont pas à blâmer ils
sont à la merci des grandes sociétés
agroalimentaires et doivent produire de
plus en plus pour tirer du jeu
la culture bio à grande échelle gagne en
popularité au canada
en saskatchewan où 35 % de tout le bio
est produit au pays
l'industrie est en pleine transformation
et la directrice de sa skoda annexes
l'organisme qui représente les
producteurs bio dans cette province
le visage du bio est en pleine mutation
en saskatchewan la taille des fermes
biologiques varient entre 500 et 19
mille hectares il ya eu une augmentation
importante du nombre de producteurs et
du nombre d'hectares consacrés au bio
la croissance du secteur bio s est de
plus en plus de fermiers à faire la
transition
il y a dix ans seuls les petits magasins
spécialisés vendait des aliments
biologiques
aujourd'hui on en trouve dans tous les
supermarchés les gens se soucient de
plus en plus de la provenance de leur
nourriture en 2012
les ventes de produits bio au canada
s'élevaient à 3 milliards et demi de
dollars
cinq ans plus tard ce chiffre avait
presque doublé
mais les défis de la production bio à
grande échelle sont nombreux
[Musique]
début juin nous sommes retournés chez
les frères ed
les récoltes commencent à sortir du sol
ainsi que les mauvaises herbes
le contrôle des mauvaises herbes et
notre plus grand défi nous manquons
d'outils pour les éliminer à grande
échelle
voici l'une des solutions à ce problème
[Musique]
une houe rotative qu'ils utilisent pour
arracher les mauvaises herbes sans pour
autant nuire ou récolte les dons pénètre
dans le sol et arrachent des mauvaises
herbes par la racine
les plans de vent tiède blé sont plus
solides et résiste parfaitement un tel
traitement
il en ressort l'an dernier nous avons
observé une diminution 60% des mauvaises
herbes
c'est considérable fioutch mais ce
désherbage mécanique sur une si grande
surface nécessite plus de main d'oeuvre
les reds doivent d'ailleurs embauché une
vingtaine d'employés à temps plein pour
assurer le bon roulement de saison on a
constaté que l'argent qu'on dépense et
pour les produits chimiques
on dépense maintenant pour embaucher du
personnel
[Musique]
la saison agricole 2019 entraîne
d'autres défis un début d'été très sec a
favorisé la propagation de la lys un
petit coléoptère les champs de canola
des ied sont ravagés on ne peut pas
appliquer pesticides donc on cherche une
solution alternative lors d'un sommet où
plus de graines de canola avec un peu de
pluie il y aura davantage de plantes y
pousseront et les pertes seront ainsi
limités
[Musique]
après la sécheresse des pluies
abondantes s'abattent sur certaines
régions des prairies à la fin de l'été
les récoltes chez les ied sont retardés
jusqu'à la mi-septembre
quelle année difficile les rendements de
certaines cultures comme le blé sont
bons
mais ailleurs c'est une autre histoire
ce champs de canola et de pois jaunes a
été envahi par les mauvaises herbes qui
ont grandi rapidement en raison des
pluies récentes le désherbage n'a pas pu
se faire dans ses champs selon rose
lequel est une plante chétive qui manque
de vigueur que les herbages mécanique la
bible vrai puisqu'il est diminué plus
faible des reins pour le moment on
ignore quel impact les mauvaises herbes
sur le rendement du canola mais on pense
quand même faire du profit car les
aliments bio se vendent plus cher
je pense changer de stratégie l'année
prochaine labourer les terres avant de
semer par exemple pour réduire les
mauvaises herbes
la culture bio à grande échelle n'en est
qu'à ses tout débuts
les sociétés agroalimentaires et
consommateurs tout le monde a le regard
tourné vers nous pour voir ce qui va se
passer
c'est un test est ce que c'est ça la
culture de l'avenir
la ferme des frères ride soulève même
des questions au sein de la communauté
bio quel impact par exemple une
production à si grande échelle
aura-t-elle sur le prix des cultures bio
c'est la principale inquiétude des
producteurs biologiques cultivés sur de
plus grandes surfaces aura forcément un
impact sur les prix mais beaucoup de
gens sont attirés par le bios et si on
continue à développer ce marché
il faudra assurément produire plus
d'animaux
[Musique]
je représente une vraie menace pour
l'agriculture conventionnelle riz
société agroalimentaire kraft ride le
des plus importants atouts de la culture
bio c'est qu'elles permettent aux
agriculteurs de rompre leur dépendance
envers les grandes sociétés
agroalimentaires
[Musique]
notre grande ferme prouve qu'il est
possible de produire ce genre
d'équipement de manière fiable et
durable
[Musique]
il compte d'ailleurs lancer dans la
prochaine année sa propre marque de
commerce pour fermer la boucle et vendre
ses produits directement sur les
étalages des supermarchés rafiot
acceptable de dieu parfois centrant
qu'une étincelle changer les choses
nous sommes peut-être c'était un sel
arrivée juste au bon moment
bon